and you're also you know what's
interesting because i i observe you
you're a happy person
you're happy you're right like you enjoy
your life
you're happy you got a great husband
congratulations
you're pregnant you have a baby on the
way you're not a miserable person and
you don't seem invested in other
people's misery
like you yeah and i think is there a
psychological component
to a lot of politics right now that
we're not realizing where you see some
of these people
when i see somebody with purple hair
screaming i go there there's something
else going on and it's not
always political it's usually just a
mental disorder
um which none of us are equipped to
address uh you know with
trying to make yourself unattractive
screaming shrieking
finding you know issues with everything
like you just anything that
you know screams normal to them they
have to attack it they're just like this
needs to go because it's too normal
um it's a horrible way to live so i
always say if you look
at the life of a leftist um
they wake up every day and they are
trying to figure out what to be upset
about
eventually that has to rot your soul
like you know to be looking around to
walk into a grocery store and be like
you know what these
jemima freaking pancakes have to go
you know what i mean like i look in and
i'm like ooh like what's in the meat
section
see what he's made up um so i just can't
imagine if they don't realize the weight
of their own mentality um and i'm the
exact ops person i'm always happy
and that's part partly because i have a
family um we just have a very good sense
of humor we just always made fun of each
other growing up we don't take ourselves
too seriously
so i think having a sense of humor just
makes life
better and the left just does not have a
sense of humor about anything well
that's true i mean one of the things
there's so many comedians that do
respect you and a lot of them don't say
so publicly because
you really you live by that code
of listen you can say whatever you want
about me i'm gonna laugh it off we did a
video where i dressed up like a corona
ball
and the corona ball said that the corona
bowl was gonna come and go up your nose
and find you in a grocery store and i
know chappelle's talked about you and
other comics and snl you
you really roll with it like you don't
care you laugh it off i love what you
said about snl i think you tweeted
your show hasn't been funny since 2009
which is true yeah why why are you able
to laugh things off and
and why are so many people on the left
but also you have certain people on the
right just not able to do it
well you know i think first and foremost
i like i said i love humor so like i
grew up watching all of the stand-ups
and i think it's it's sad
um that comedians aren't allowed to say
um things unless they're politically
correct political practice is not funny
it's just not funny right um so like i
always say uh
it was chris chris rock's bigger and
blacker it's one of my favorite
all-time favorite stand-ups and you if
you watch it from start to finish now he
could have
never performed this in 2020 um he would
have been burned over the coals
um and what's beautiful about it is he
starts out the first thing he says is
racially charged he comes out on stage
and he's like white people in the back
tonight
then he starts going on about all of
these stereotypes making fun of
black people for the baby mama culture
making fun of white people being like if
it's a school shooter you know it's a
white kid
right you know all these things like you
could never say today
and by the end of it this incredible
thing happens where everyone in the
audience
no one escaped whether you were chinese
black white gay straight no one escaped
and you sort of realized you know what
we all kind of suck and we're in that
together
and there's there's a beauty in that
there's a humanity in that of and not
taking yourself so seriously
and being able to laugh at yourself like
i appreciate the stereotype even the
caricature
of candace owens right so like i found
your thing to be very funny because it
was hitting at this caricature of like
canisters doesn't think i'm real and
that's funny and
i should laugh at that and not be like
how could he make fun of a woman
of color expressing her opinion about a
panda it's just so boring it's funny